er bedeute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute sind wir endlich
mal wieder zu zweit am start und zwar
mit dem young ist nicht mit max hey ich
bin mag dir machen eines snap chat
rückwärts challenge die ganze geschichte
funktioniert so leute max wird auf
seinem handy ein lied abspielen was ich
auf jeden fall kenne und maxis
musikgeschmack ist bisschen näher an
meinem max wird die wieder dann aber mit
snapshot aufnehmen rückwärts laufen
lassen und mir dann vor spielen so dass
ich sie erraten muss sich in max treten
heute quasi gegeneinander an das heißt
max wird versuchen die lieder so zu
wählen dass ich jetzt zwar kenne aber
nicht erkenne in dem er ganz bestimmte
die daraus wenig wird versuchen sie zu
erraten und das von battle zwischen uns
beiden
hier sind wir in der ganzen geschichte
in skype und damit ich nicht höre was
max in dem moment auf dem youtube er
sich selbstverständlich bin ich okay
sebastian wir sind so weit bist du
bereit für nummer eins am ready und los
ja es ist toll was ist das lieber oder
ja das ist schon mal richtig remix
nehmen das glaubt dass das problem
einfach dass du dich nicht mit seiner
musik auskennt sondern
wobei das eigentlich glaube ich nur 100
millionen prozent
sorry ich hab ich habe vielleicht
angefangen so pastiors rechner sorry
ging es keine autos kein e10 für mich
mag sie muss sich ranhalten denn da wird
dein kompletter unterkiefer rasiert ok
ich glaube du kriegst du auch da wieder
auf den auf die spur was es sein könnte
allerdings darf sie erst mal anhören
würde ich sagen okay du musst hier war
anhalten also weil wenn ich jetzt den
punkt machen schießen 20 wächter noch
ein paar asse instant verloren
du hast du nur einmal anhören und 321
america ist richtig aber jetzt jetzt du
wolltest du willst du kriegst du nach
außen was ist das ich wollte halt akten
billiger machen die zuschauer auch
kennen aber das wird vielleicht zu
einfach machen
ich weiß nicht was du lieber hier kein
problem aber gar nicht höher board
computer ipad auf
wie oft habe ich an ein einziges mal
ja sicherlich mussten dessen für regeln
und lust das war irgendwann ich sage
wenn ich vorher das spiel weil sie
sofort rasse ist also kennt das lied
sehr gut für mich
willst du nochmal anhören wie wir mit
den liga dass ich mit einem anderen auf
zumindest bei dem dann müssen es gleich
nochmal neu verhandeln aber man kann es
ja auch müll aus dem kopf direkt
abstimmen was aber gehört hat ich
bereite es mal vor in im richtig du
wirst jetzt direkt nahm von linkin park
das habe ich eine ewigkeit nicht mehr
gehört
kurz immer schwer machen aber leute
jetzt kommt
ok kennst du natürlich aber leider nicht
geklappt youtubes bereitet das nächste
vor das nächste raus 221 leute ok gil
bereich rallye alles entscheidendes
sorgen 3 2 1
künstler ich habe eine idee aber was ist
wenn ich falsch rat eines falschen ich
habe einen punkt für mich dann stets
weit zu sein
es gibt einfach ich weiß linkin park hat
sich rückwärts auch überhaupt nicht
danach angehört ich habe einen verdacht
leute so einen verdacht
ok paket risiko eminems relapse scheiße
was
dickenberg was sagst du beginn weg bin
ja dann meine freunde kommt es jetzt
darauf an alles entscheidend stärken das
ging gut kennst du eigentlich gut dass
bietigheim persönlichkeit nicht mehr
gehört aber das ist übrigens nicht kennt
das leid das ist ein rapper aus der
westcoast starten also gangsta rap wir
hatten natürlich weil wir auch gangster
sind wir auch viel mit waffen
kriminalität zu tun weil seit ich würde
das allerletzte aufnehmen jetzt auch
nicht was gemein das okay ich mache
nicht ich mache was was du wirklich hin
bringen kann hier aber allen vielleicht
auch nicht so leicht dass jetzt die
schwere aufgabe sicher nicht so leicht
zu leiten ok erwarte weiter bevor du
stehst
wie oft habe ich raten also nehmen wie
oft darf ich mir anhören 0 x private
jessica sie falsch beraten was das
gleiche ich das nochmal anhören ist ich
hab ich auch schon geraten
nein das nun raten ist alles
entscheidende lied ich bin sehr gespannt
wie sorten 3 2 1
okay okay okay okay okay ich weiß ich
bin mir nicht sicher welches lied das
ist aber es ist mac miller auf watching
you bis motorsound auf das richtig und
red dot music music hat sich so ähnlich
an
irritiert nicht so ähnlich an rückwärts
ist so schwer
ja klar dass man entweder letzter punkt
bei grassers album ja echt mal gesucht
von mac miller gab es ein bisschen
richtigkeit gesucht und ich höre auch
glaube ich wieder heute abend wenn ich
zu maxim eine familie hochphase in
diesem sinne ist laut sehr gute musik
dabei hört euch das gerne mal an
feinste erlesene perlen aus dem musik
junge ausgesucht von matt es in diesem
format heute wären seine leute macht bis
später ihrem stammtisch bis bald machte
bis bald auch bei nacht vorbei